all right there is a major major
development in the Donald Trump doesn't
pay federal taxes story remember the
back story is that the New York Times
over the weekend
detonated a bombshell by reporting that
Donald Trump using this loophole that
benefits wealthy families and wealthy
individuals declared a nearly billion
dollar loss on his 1995 tax returns now
that possibly could have allowed him to
avoid paying federal taxes for up to 18
years now we don't know because we
haven't seen those tax returns post 1995
at the debate at the first presidential
debate when Donald Trump suggested I'm
sorry when Hillary Clinton suggested
that Donald Trump didn't pay taxes
Donald Trump seemingly reflexively
almost uncontrollably responded that
makes me smart it turns out that Donald
Trump who claimed that it is smart for
him not to pay taxes actually has a long
history of slamming other people for not
paying taxes and critiquing people who
do not pay federal taxes back on July
18th of 2011 sit down for this because
this is just the cherry on top of the
cake of hypocrisy that is Donald Trump
on taxes 2011 July Trump appears on Fox
News and he was asked about a comment
President Obama made that rich people
should make some sacrifice for the
country by paying more in taxes listen
to what Donald Trump said on Fox News
when when the president Donald talks
about there has to be shared sacrifice
yeah you know there are a lot of people
in this country over half don't even pay
any federal taxes so he's really talking
about you you're gonna have to sacrifice
more hmm well you know I don't mind
sacrificing for the country to be honest
with you but you know you do have a
problem because half of the people don't
pay any tax and when he's talking about
that he's talking about people that
aren't also working that are not
contributing to this society and it's a
problem but we have 50% it just hit the
50 percent mark 50% of the people are
paying no tax wait a second so Trump
criticizes people
not paying taxes in 2011 they're lazy
but when he doesn't pay taxes he's smart
for that interesting well maybe it was
just a one-time thing well no it wasn't
here is a tweet that Donald Trump put
out in 2012 February of 2012 about the
same topic half of Americans don't pay
income tax despite crippling government
debt well ok fine I mean he showed up on
Fox News once and then he sent one tweet
about people not paying taxes but I'm
sure that's it right David right wrong
more recently Donald Trump again
reiterated that 50% of Americans are
Free Riders not contributing to society
and expecting to be taken care of by
others this is from a June 2015
interview with Fox News host Sean
Hannity where Trump said and I will put
the quote up for you the problem we have
right now we have a society that sits
back and says we don't have to do
anything eventually the 50% cannot carry
and it's unfair to them but cannot carry
the other 50% so the obvious story
number one is this may not come as a
surprise to you Donald Trump is a total
hypocrite do as I say not as I do no
credibility it's a total joke but I want
to take it a step further because
there's this common right wing talking
point about half of Americans pay no
taxes and we've got to debunk it you
need to understand this ok it's true
that close to 50% of Americans do not
pay federal income tax because they
don't even make enough money to pay that
tax and that's a problem ok but many of
those people are working for very very
low wages and they are paying countless
other taxes Social Security taxes state
taxes and fees sales taxes excise taxes
on and on and on the Republicans like to
use this to say what half of Americans
are just paying no taxes suggesting they
live this tax-free life well no they
don't even make enough money to pay
federal income tax but there are paying
countless other taxes and as usual Pat
it's projection from Trump we talked
about it earlier and this is yet another
exam
he's the guy not paying taxes he
criticizes others for not paying taxes
yeah it's a classic case of projection
and there's so many other examples you
can go to the paper play scandal that he
criticized the Clinton Foundation for
yeah turns out the donald trump
foundation had to cease and assist yep
and there's you know so many insulting
other people saying that people are mean
to him where he does the same thing yeah
the the one that sticks out to me is
when he suggested that megyn kelly the
the primary debate moderator moderator
was bleeding from her private parts and
said other vile things and then after
the fact said you know megyn kelly she
was really not nice to me she's been not
nice to me yeah it's it's there's zero
credibility whatsoever and this tax
issue i'm now genuinely wondering how
bad what's in Trump's taxes is and I'm
thinking if when this entire thing
started Trump diffused it prevented it
from building into this gigantic
elephant in the room that it now is and
just released the taxes it would have
had to have been really bad what was
revealed by those taxes to be worse than
the situation he finds himself in now
we're a month out from the election
almost every day now there's some really
problematic thing happening with Donald
Trump's taxes first it's that he took
this loss in 95 that could have allowed
him to not pay taxes for 18 years now
all the all of these clips and tweets
have been uncovered of Trump criticizing
others for not paying taxes after saying
he's smart for not doing it whatever is
in there must be disastrously bad for it
to be potentially worse than what Donald
Trump is experiencing now we will take a
break I want to remind you that we are
on Facebook at facebook.com slash David
Pakman show